the Milky Way is a tremendous structure
in space containing billions of stars
and trillions of planets
in their turn these objects are
surrounded by gigantic clouds of
Interstellar dust and scorching Hot Gas
streams
all these components make up the bizarre
and fascinating picture called Galaxy
and today we invite you on an exciting
journey across it
we'll start out near the star system
closest to our sun Alpha Centauri
whizzing on hundreds of times faster
than light we will fly around some of
the most remarkable Stars closest to us
and then briefly stop near an unusual
Planet the surface is completely
submerged by perpetually boiling ocean
placing our lives in Peril we will
nevertheless approach an unstable
pulsating giant enjoying its last
Millennia of life
and then pay a visit to the most extreme
and forbidding exoplanets
[Music]
straight after that it will be time for
the most mysterious and dangerous
objects in the Milky Way Black Hills
and then we will pierce the Galaxy in a
swift flight from the bright Center
richly illumined by the Stars to its
very edge concealing mysterious Dark
Matter let's get ready and we begin
[Music]
[Music]
the Earth has been emitting structured
radio signals into space for around 100
years now
the radio noise from the earth reached
dozens of other Stellar systems long ago
including Arcturus lying 37 light years
away from us and DOW de Baron which is
roughly 65 light years away
besides our radio signals may be heard
on the surfaces of a great number of
potentially habitable exoplanets like
cross 1 to 8B or glisa 667cc
still the triple Stellar system of Alpha
Centauri Remains the closest neighbor of
the sun which automatically makes it the
first obvious candidate for the
destination of the first ever
Interstellar flight Alpha Centauri is
known to be a multiple Stellar system
made up of three components two of the
larger ones are relatively close to each
other seen with the naked eye they
appear to be a single source of light
the two components follow a slightly
elongated orbit around the common Mass
center which takes around 80 years to
complete
the maximal distance between the Stars
May reach 35 astronomical units with a
minimal distance reaching 11.2
astronomical units
as for the distance between these
objects and the sun it is reportedly
4.36 light years the most massive the
largest and the brightest component in
the system is dubbed Alpha Centauri a
this is a main sequence star with a mass
of about 108 percent that of the sun its
radius is reportedly 1.22 times that of
our sun even though the surface
temperature and the spectral class of
Alpha Centauri a are close to those of
our star it emits one and a half times
as much energy
there are no confirmed exoplanets in the
environs of this star however while the
star was being observed in the infrared
in 2021 some evidence was found there
being a planet-like object close by
according to preliminary estimates its
mass may be anything from 9 to 35 Earth
masses and its radius May measure 3.3 to
7 times that of our planet
1.1 astronomical units away from its
parent star the hypothetical Celestial
body completes a full orbit around it
within roughly a year
additional observations are called for
to verify the data which can be done
with the help of either the James Webb
Telescope or else earth-based
observatories
the second component of the system is
called Alpha Centauri b or ptolemon and
it also falls into the class of main
sequence Stars however its mass is 10
percent less than that of the Sun and
its radius measures only 86 percent or
so that of the sun ptoleman is also
slightly cooler than our star its
surface temperature is reportedly
5260 Kelvin or slightly lower than 5000
degrees Celsius
with these factors combined the
celestial object has an orange Hue and
its Luminosity is on average twice as
low as that of our sun
incidentally Alpha Centauri B emits a
lot more energy in the X-ray range
compared with other objects of its class
besides the star is peculiar for its
temper and there are bright flares and
ejections to be seen on its surface
no confirmed exoplanets have been
detected near this star either in 2012 a
group of astronomers from the Geneva
Observatory put forward a suggestion
that there was a planet very close to it
whose orbital period was around 12 days
and whose radius measured slightly less
than that of the Earth the suggestion
was made based on four years of
observation of the star's proper motion
however three years later a mathematical
error was detected to have been made in
the course of data processing and so the
idea of there being a planet was found
to be erroneous
the third component of the system is a
stark contrast to the first two it is a
red dwarf with a mass approximately 12
percent that of the sun its size is
about seven times smaller than that of
the sun its surface temperature is only
slightly higher than 3000 Kelvin and its
Luminosity is just a measly 0.17 percent
that of the Sun
of all the components of the Alpha
Centauri system it is this dim space
object that is the closest one to the
sun lying 4.25 light years away from it
this is what earned its name Proxima
Centauri which is Latin for closest
besides the object is getting nearer and
nearer thus in 26 700 years it will be
only a bit more than three light years
away
still this star cannot be seen from the
earth on account of its slow luminosity
Proxima is noticeably far from its two
companions in the Stellar system
this distance is currently around 13 000
astronomical units or 0.21 light years
but in the next 300 000 years it is
expected to gradually shrink to Just 4
100 astronomical units
it takes Proxima 547
000 years to orbit around the system's
common Mass center
unlike its two larger neighbors the
Proxima santori system boasts two
confirmed exoplanets as well as at least
one hypothetical object
sides studies of the star in the
infrared allowed scientists to assume
that there is a dust ring and probably a
great number of small celestial objects
like asteroids or comets
the first planet in the system Proxima
Centauri B was detected in 2016 by the
radial velocities method four years
later in 2020 it was confirmed by
spectrographic studies with the help of
the largest earth-based telescope on our
planet VLT the very large telescope
according to the updates the exoplanet
lies 0.05 astronomical units away from
its parent star and it takes it roughly
11 Earth days to complete a full orbit
estimates show that the planet's mass is
10 to 20 percent bigger than that of the
earth and its radius measures about 1.3
times that of our planet
mathematical modeling revealed that
Proxima Centauri b gets about one and a
half times as little thermal energy from
its Star as does the earth from the sun
its average temperature is 234 Kelvin or
39 degrees Celsius below zero which
means that hypothetically there could be
liquid water in some areas on the planet
as the celestial body is extremely close
to its host star however it is likely to
be tidally locked so it faces the star
with one on the same side a dense
atmosphere could compensate with sharp
contrasts and temperatures which are
inevitable in such conditions but just
like any other red dwarves Proxima
Centauri is often seen to eject Stellar
Mata also ionizing radiation flares are
observed
it is assumed that such activity
gradually destroys the atmosphere of the
closest objects
a powerful magnetic field that could be
encompassing Proxima Centauri B could
offer some protection against the
destructive process but chances that
there is any magnetic field there or
thin
in the year 2020 another planet was
confirmed to exist in the system a space
object dubbed Proxima Centauri C lies
roughly one and a half astronomical
units away from the center of the system
its orbital cycle is slightly over five
years as for the object's Mass it may be
six to eight times that of the Earth but
its radius hasn't been estimated at the
time this video is posted depending on
its size meanwhile the exoplanet will
fall either in the category of many
Neptunes or super Earths as Proxima
Centauri C lies quite a big distance
away from its parent star its
temperature is remarkably low about 39
Kelvin or 234 degrees Celsius below zero
According to some observations the
planets may have a ring system whose
radius is roughly five times that of
Jupiter also based on the latest data
from VLT a remarkably small exoplanet is
expected to lie in 0.029 astronomical
units away from its parent star whose
mass is about 25 percent that of the
Earth
it does exist and if this isn't another
measurement error a year on this planet
lasts about five Earth days and the
surface temperature there could be 360
Kelvin or 87 degrees Celsius
whether this space object is really
there or not remains an open question
and additional confirmations are called
for
Alpha Centauri has been listening to our
radio signals for over a hundred years
now but the 40 trillion kilometers of
space vacuum between us are too
overwhelming for us to cover at this
point it takes light over four years to
get there but for humans such speeds are
still in the realm of fancy even today's
swiftest state-of-the-art spacecraft
would need tens of thousands of years to
cover this distance
however application of Advanced
Technologies could theoretically greatly
reduce travel time since the very dawn
of space exploration projects of a great
number of spacecraft have been suggested
that hypothetically would have been able
to negotiate into Stellar distances
nevertheless not a single one of them
has been actually designed
most of these would-be missions were
forgotten but one is still under active
consideration
this is the Breakthrough star shot
program which implies sending as many as
a thousand microprobes to Proxima
santori as soon as in the first half of
this Century they will not measure over
a centimeter in size as special thin and
durable sales are planned to be created
to Aid the probes along the sails will
be blown out as it were by impulses of a
highly powerful earth-based laser
estimates show that an Interstellar
probe like that is going to be leaving
the solar system at a speed roughly 20
percent that of the speed of light with
the overall travel time around 20 years
after that it will take another five
years or so for the data collected by
the mission to reach the Earth
[Music]
by Galactic standards the area of space
on the outer edge of the solar system is
considered to be sparsely populated by
both stars and other space objects still
approximately 50 Stellar systems are
known to be located within the radius of
15 light years from the Earth
some of them are single Stars While
others contain two components and more
which is why the total number of stars
in this area reaches 65.
many of them have exoplanets and
protoplanetary disks made up of gas and
dust where Celestial body formation
processes are still in progress in order
to analyze this great variety we'll have
to map out the environs
as we slowly recede from our home planet
we will cover dozens of light years of
space and visit quite a few remote
worlds
it is time to set out to the Stars
having traveled six light years away
from the sun we will reach our first
stop a small red dwarf designation
gj699 also known as Barnard's star
it is remarkable for its incredible
travel speed across the sky and also for
the fact that it's capable of crossing
the lunar disk in the course of 180
years this is due not only to its close
proximity to us but also to its great
proper motion
Barnard's star is moving towards the
solar system at a speed of slightly over
100 kilometers per second and is going
to become our closest star in about 10
000 years
by then the distance between Barnard's
star and our sun will be just 3.8 light
years
but the Red Dwarf is so dim that it will
not be visible even at such a small
distance and it will be possible to
observe it only through optical devices
the star's mass is just 17 percent that
of the Sun and its radius is six times
the smallest out of our star just like
all red dwarves Barnard star is quite
cool with a surface temperature just
3134 Kelvin or slightly under 2 900
Degrees Celsius
with these characteristics taken into
account it isn't surprising that the
object's Luminosity is 2300 times lower
than that of our parents star in 2018
the results of a 20-year observation of
the star's proper motion were published
which may provide evidence for the
presence of an exoplanet nearby the
calculations show it to be a code super
Earth with a mass of not less than 3.2
times that of the Earth
the planet named
gj699b is located about 0.4 astronomical
units from the center of the system and
takes 233 days to complete a full orbit
around its parent star unfortunately the
exoplanet follows an orbit that does not
lie between the earth and its parents
star so it's hardly feasible to carry
out spectral analysis of the object
still mathematical modeling may give us
some insights into what it's like
as bonded star is very dim its planetary
companion receives 50 times less energy
than does the Earth from the Sun
that is why the temperature on the
celestial body's surface is extremely
low just 105 Kelvin or 168 degrees
Celsius below zero
however it cannot be ruled out the tidal
disturbances or radioactive decay may
have released enough energy in the
planet's interior to form a warm
subsurface ocean
if that is the case the potential life
in its depths would have had ample time
to gradually develop
for among the known Stars Barnard's star
appears to be one of the oldest
according to estimates its age is over
10 billion years which is only a
fraction of the expected lifespan of a
star
as it is located quite close and is
moving in a favorable Direction
Barnard's star is one of the highest
priority objects for a potential
Interstellar flight time will show if
spacecraft launched from Earth will ever
reach it
meanwhile on the other side of the sun
there lies the almost exact opposite of
the dim red dwarf
of course we're talking about Sirius the
brightest star in the night sky which is
8.6 light years away from our planet
from Earth the star appears to be a
single light source but close inspection
revealed that it is not a single object
but a binary star the two components of
the system are currently at their
maximum distance from each other about
30 astronomical units
the main star also called serious a is a
bright blue and white star with a mass
two times that of the Sun
at the same time it is about 70 percent
larger in diameter and its surface
temperature reaches 10 000 Kelvin
because of this serious a emits 25 times
more energy than our sun
the second object known as Sirius B is
barely visible against the background of
its bright and massive companion it is a
wide dwarf with a radius of about 6 000
kilometers and a mass very close to that
of the Sun
like all stars of this type its surface
temperature is extremely high reaching
25 000 Kelvin
however due to its small size this white
dwarf is about a thousand times dimmer
than its Stellar companion
after long and persistent research no
signs of planets have been found in the
vicinity of Sirius
the reason for this may lie in the
comparatively young age of the Stellar
system or else the special position of
the ecliptic plane because of this the
hypothetical exoplanets do not pass
between the light source and the Earth
and therefore cannot be detected by the
transit method
another hypothesis claims that Sirius B
exhausted its Stellar fuel supply
roughly 120 million years ago and
transformed into a red giant
so afterwards it shed its outer layers
turning into a compact and very hot by
dwarf as a result the protoplanetary gas
and dust disc enveloping the young
Stellar system at the time was destroyed
by this explosion its remnants scattered
into the space around denying the
forming planets any chance of survival
currently both components of the system
are moving around a common Mass center
in moderately elongated orbits
completing one every 50 years
over the next sixty Thousand Years
Sirius will gradually approach Earth
becoming brighter and more visible in
the night sky
the minimum distance between us will be
about seven and a half light years after
which the system will start to slowly
drift away from us
things will go on like this for about
another 660 million years after which
serious a will meet the same fate as its
companion
for a brief moment a massive flare will
boost its Luminosity by a factor of
thousands
but within a few months the star will
fade completely Vanishing from the sky
forever
leaving the vicinity of Sirius permeated
by lethal ultraviolet radiation and
Stellar Wind we will perform a maneuver
near the solar system to reach a small
star 14 light years from the earth it is
designated differently in different
catalogs and one of its names is Wolf
1061.
the star is a red dwarf with a radius of
about 30 percent that of the Sun
its mass is about four times smaller
than that of our star and its surface
temperature is
3272 Kelvin or about 3000 degrees
Celsius like all objects in its class
wolf 1061 is extremely dim its
Luminosity is only 0.14 percent that of
the Sun so the star is not visible to
the naked eye from Earth
however this red dwarf has one of the
most abundant and diverse planetary
environments of any Stellar system
nearest
as many as three exoplanets have been
discovered in its vicinity all of them
Rocky and similar in composition to
Earth but still conditions on each of
the three celestial bodies differ
considerably
the first are closest exoplanet to the
parent star is called wolf 1061b it is
located
.038 astronomical units from the center
of the system and completes a full orbit
around it roughly every five days
the object has a mass in the range of
one and a half to Two Earths and a
radius twenty percent greater than that
of our planet
it is likely that the celestial body is
tidally locked and faces its star with
one side at all times
for this reason the temperature on the
day side of the planet is extremely high
and the flares and Stellar Winds of the
star so close to it virtually rule out
any chance of there being an atmosphere
all these factors make the exoplanets
completely unsuitable for the Genesis
and support of life
the second object in the system wolf
1061c is located .089 astronomical units
from its star and completes a full orbit
around it roughly every 18 days
thus it is within the habitable zone of
the star and can be considered a
potentially habitable Celestial body
wolf 1061c is about three to four times
more massive than our planet and belongs
to the class of super Earths
observations show that its radius is
about 1.6 times that of Earth while the
gravity on its surface is calculated to
be 60 percent higher than what we're
used to the exoplanet receives
noticeably less energy from its star
than the earth does from the Sun so its
temperature of equilibrium is much lower
it is 223 Kelvin or about 50 degrees
Celsius below zero which is slightly
higher than on Mars
nevertheless given variations in
temperature during the day and from
season to season liquid water May well
exist on a surface of the celestial body
with a dense atmosphere with a
pronounced greenhouse effect this
probability is even higher and
conditions on a planet could approach
favorable ones
of all the potentially habitable
exoplanets known to date
wolf 1061c is one of the closest
ranking fifth on the list
the third object in the system is called
wolf 1061d
it follows a clearly elongated orbit
with a distance between the parents star
and the aphelium reaching 0.73
astronomical units
as for the perihelium it lies much
closer to the system's Center just 0.21
astronomical units away
it takes the celestial object about 217
Earth days to complete a full year
rotation
the mass of wolf 1061d is calculated to
be roughly 7.7 times that of our Earth
if this Celestial body turns out to be a
rocky object
its radius is supposed to measure about
1.7 times that of the Earth
if on the other hand this planet falls
in the category of many Neptunes with a
thick multi-layer atmosphere its
diameter is supposed to be not less than
2.2 times that of our planet
in spite of a comparatively High
eccentricity of its orbit wolf 1061d
never enters its star's habitable zone
the celestial body is likely to be
completely unsuitable for supporting
life but may pose a great scientific
interest in terms of planetary Evolution
this system is one of top priority
destinations for future Explorations and
it is highly probable that there are new
discoveries to be soon made in it
in addition to everything else the star
wolf 1061 is also remarkable for its
position
which is virtually at the very edge of
the so-called local Interstellar Cloud
it is an area in space filled with hot
but extremely rarefied hydrogen
its temperature measures about 7000
Kelvin
and on average there is just 0.3 of an
atom to be found in one cubic centimeter
of space here
it is about twice as little as the
average value in the Milky Way the solar
system has been moving through the local
Cloud for the past ten thousand years
its average diameter is about 30 light
years but our system is almost at its
very edge
Alpha Centauri for example is already in
the neighboring so-called g-cloud we on
the other hand will spend about another
2 000 years within our Cloud after which
we will enter an even thinner and hotter
region
the local Interstellar Cloud was formed
by the Collision of two giant bubbles of
hot Cosmic gas
it has a momentum of its own which is
perpendicular to the direction of the
Solar System's motion and also has a
magnetic field and radiation
fortunately despite the high energy of
the interstellar gas particles that make
up the cloud there is no threat to
organisms on Earth the solar wind is a
reliable protection against Cosmic
hydrogen and the Earth's dense
atmosphere takes the head of particles
that do break through the heliosphere
still traces of the isotope ions 60 also
called Interstellar iron have been found
in the ice of Antarctica
it is thought to have arrived to Earth
from no other place but the local
Interstellar cloud
[Music]
as we continue our journey through space
we will soon get to a rather unusual
star called AP colombe located
27.4 light years away from Earth
first and foremost it draws our
attention because it was born just 40
million years ago when the dinosaurs
would have long since died out on our
planet what is even more striking is
that its birth took place in a
completely different region of the
Galaxy
450 light years from the object's
present position
young Stars usually remain close to
their Stellar nursery for quite a long
period of time up to several hundred
million years if you analyze the
movement of AP colombe however you will
find that it probably previously
belonged to the open cluster ic2391
the cluster has about 30 Stars United by
a common origin and direction of
movement but a few million years ago one
of them exploded shattering the delicate
equilibrium of a multitude of cosmic
bodies
this catastrophe gave the youngster an
additional momentum that swiftly
expelled it from his birthplace
a very small red dwarf with a mass just
13 percent out of the sun this time it's
four times more energy than any other
known Celestial body with the same
parameters
in addition its radius is twice as large
as calculated based on the modern
Stellar Structure Theory
strangely enough another unusual feature
of the star has helped to provide
answers to these riddles
according to spectral analysis of its
radiation the Stellar Mata of AP colombe
contains an abnormally large amount of
lithium
normally this element is found in
abundance and protistellar clumps but it
burns out completely after the start of
a thermonuclear reaction
this means that the star is very young
and at the very beginning of its
formation
not even in the main sequence phase yet
as a consequence AP colombe is unstable
and explosive in nature
it is prone to Violent outbursts and
Stellar Mata ejections during which its
Luminosity may increase by up to 10
times for a short while
such events would normally threaten
exoplanets nearby
stripping off their atmosphere and
sterilizing their surface with
ultraviolet radiation
as it is observations show that there
are no large space objects within 4.5
astronomical units of this star
in all likelihood it is too young for
the formation of fully fledged planets
nevertheless it is a unique Cosmic body
very important for understanding early
evolutionary stages of stars
as we've seen not every Star has a
planetary system
so our next stop is near the orange
dwarf gleasa 370 37 light years from
Earth
in 2011 a single exoplanet was
discovered near it designated glisa 370b
the object was discovered with the use
of the radial velocity method and has a
mass of three to four Earths
according to current understanding of
the formation of celestial bodies the
discovered world is most likely a rocky
planet with a radius about 30 percent
larger than the Earth's under such
conditions the gravity on its surface
may be at least 40 percent higher than
what we're used to
Glacier 370b is located at a distance of
0.26 astronomical units from its parent
star and completes an annual rotation in
54.4 Earth days
thus the exoplanet is in a habitable
zone of its star
if the Albedo value of its surface is
close to that of the Earth
then the average temperature of the
celestial body should be about 25
degrees Celsius which is a few degrees
higher than on our Earth
the fact that an exoplanet is located
quite far from its parents star suggests
that it is not tidally locked and has
its own Dion or cycle
this contributes to an even a
distribution of heat over the surface of
the celestial body
which is a consequence May create a
milder climate a moderately High Gravity
should smooth out the planet's terrain
which combined with an abundance of
liquid water may cause vast Seas to form
both warm and shallow
such places have traditionally been
considered the most comfortable for the
Genesis and support of life
at the time of its Discovery Glacier
370b was considered one of the most
favorable exoplanets for potential
biological life
however more recent research has
suggested that conditions on its surface
are somewhat less attractive than
previously thought
in particular the atmosphere of the
celestial body may be too dense never
pronounced greenhouse effect
still even according to the most
pessimistic predictions the average
temperature on the surface of the object
does not exceed 78 degrees Celsius
which corresponds to a temperature range
of about 30 to 100 degrees Celsius
given that our planet's climate was
about the same During the archaean
period glycer 370b remains a very
promising exoplanet for the search for
extraterrestrial life which means that
its exploration must continue
if we stop and look around for a while
we will find that we have already
traveled more than 50 light years away
from our solar system
there are over a thousand stars within
its radius most of them single Stars
others are binary stars or even groups
of stars the most striking example is
caster a complex and surprising system
of as many as six components
this Stella system is located 50 light
years away from Earth and is visible to
the naked eye as a single source of
light
as the second brightest object in the
constellation Gemini and the 23rd
brightest in the night sky in General
Caster has been known to humans since
ancient times
as the system has as many as six
components it has a rather complex
structure
the two brightest of these cast to A and
B are bluish white serious-like stars
each with a red dwarf companion nearby
the distance between the mass centers of
these binaries is about 110 astronomical
units and it takes them 445 years to
complete a full orbit
about 600 astronomical units from cast
to A and B there is another compact
binary system consisting of a pair of
almost identical red Dwarfs
each has a mass of about 0.6 times that
of the Sun and has a surface temperature
of about
3900 Kelvin
the two stars are so close together that
they take less than 20 hours to complete
a rotation
they move around the system's common
Mass center following a very oblong
elliptical orbit with an orbital period
of about 14 000 years
so far no confirmed exoplanets have been
found in the Caster system
but if they do exist they're most likely
to be located here
the faintest component of the system
in 2018 for example astronomers detected
variations in the orbital period of
Caster sea which implies there may be a
brown dwarf nearby about 49 times more
massive than Jupiter
according to calculations it is located
14 astronomical units from the parent
star and completes a full orbit around
it every 54 years
it is possible that like many red
dwarves cast to see has Rocky exoplanets
close by
in this case the skyline of such a
hypothetical object must present a truly
incredible spectacle on one side a
considerable part of it is occupied by
two Crimson Stars circling the sky
without stopping while on the other side
the Eternal Twilight is diffused by the
light of a pair of stars either of them
hundreds of times brighter than the
Earth's moon
whether this is actually the case can it
yet be verified at this point
although the stars were visited are
great distances apart they're all within
a single structure stretching for the
total of about 300 light years
this is called the local bubble and
contains not only thousands of stars but
also several large structures including
the local Interstellar cloud
the local bubble was formed by
successive explosions of several
supernovae that occurred between 10 and
15 million years ago it has a giant
cloud of interstellar gas heated to 1
million Kelvin because of its high
temperature the gas tends to expand so
its density is about 10 times lower than
the galactic average
in addition the hot ionized hydrogen
constantly emits x-rays fortunately the
magnetic fields of the Sun and the Earth
as well as the atmosphere of the planet
successfully protect us from the harmful
radiation
the local bubble is bordered by other
similar formations
for example slightly away from the
direction of the cellular system's
motion is the so-called bubble one
formed by Supernova explosions in the
vicinity of Antares this giant Cosmic
structure has been actively interacting
with our bubble for a long time which
has caused the formation of tremendous
compactions located at the region at the
edge
the center of the neighboring bubble is
about 500 light years from us and the
solar system will reach its margins in a
few tens of millions of years
clouds of scorching hot gas and open
clusters Giant nebulae and Stellar
streams
all these Majestic Cosmic structures add
up to a single system called galaxies in
turn they combine to form Galactic
filaments giant streams on walls
stretching for billions of light years
this forms the large-scale structure of
the universe
with countless different stars and
worlds lurking in its depths
who knows what we're eventually defined
among them
[Music]
the first steps in theoretical
confirmation of there being ocean worlds
out there that is planets fully covered
in water were made back in the 1970s
that is when evidence was found that
radioactive decay in a planet's interior
and tidal forces may cause water ice to
melt and subsequently form huge oceans
in all likelihood similar processes take
place on Jupiters and Saturn's
satellites
however these celestial bodies remain
eyesbound as they lie too far away from
the Sun whose Rays would otherwise melt
the thick layers of ice
but when we talk about an ocean planet a
slightly different type of space object
is meant
the term implies that the ocean on a
planet's surface isn't concealed under a
layer of ice and its depth measures more
than 100 kilometers
theoretical calculations of these
planets formation and evolution
processes were carried out in 2004 by
French astrophysicists headed by
Christoph Satan
according to this theory if the mass of
a forming planet is more than 10 times
that of the Earth this starts to
actively attract hydrogen and helium
from the gas and dust cloud around it in
this manner with time it grows into a
gas giant
by contrast if this planet's mass is
just six to eight Earth masses the new
planet is going to be comprised of ice
and rocks roughly in equal measure
just to compare the mass total of all
water in the global ocean on our Earth
accounts for just .025 of the Earth's
total mass
in this case provided a space object's
orbit lies far from the host star this
object is going to be either a nice
giant or a code super Earth radioactive
decay taking place inside the core will
help melt some portion of the ice
which in its turn will help form a
subsurface ocean by the planet's outer
layers will still remain Frozen
if the planet happens to find itself in
its star's habitable zone its outer
layers will melt and spill all over the
surface in a boundless ocean
theoretical calculations show that a
planet with a mass six to eight times
out of the earth may have a layer of
water over a hundred kilometers thick
the pressure exerted by this amount of
water May reach 20 000 atmospheres
depending on temperature impurities and
other parameters
this is enough for some special exotic
varieties of ice to form like one's
remaining solid even at high
temperatures
in addition unlike the familiar water
ice these modifications would be heavier
than liquid water
for example the density of ice 7 which
is likely to form in these conditions
should be around 1 650 kilos per cubic
meter
this ice settles on the planet's Ocean's
bottom and forms a massive cryosphere
that envelops the more massive core
the opportunity to put these theoretical
assumptions to test arose when a tiny
and dim star was spotted 42 light years
away from the Earth
it was dubbed gleesa 1214.
the diameter of this red dwarf turned
out to be five times smaller than that
of the sun with its mass just 15.7
percent that of the Sun at the same time
glisa 1214 is 300 times dimmer than our
parent star while its surface
temperature is only 3000 Kelvin or 2 700
degrees Celsius
there is nothing particularly remarkable
about the star itself
to be blunt it is just another
non-descript red dwarf that looks like
any of the billions of other stars in
our galaxy
however in 2009 a solitary planet was
detected in its environs which was
dubbed gleesa 1214b with its diameter
measuring two and a half times that of
the Earth this exoplanet is just six and
a half times heavier than our home
planet
straightforward calculations show the
Free Fall acceleration on the
exoplanet's surface to be just 91
percent that of the Earth
the average density of gleesa 1214b is
approximately
1870 kilos per cubic meter
judging by this comparatively small
value the exoplanet cannot realistically
be made up of mostly metals and rocks as
is the case with our Earth for example
but incidentally this average density
value seems to confirm the assumption
that the astronomical body is 75 percent
water or water ice and just 25 trucks
thus it appears safe to suggest that
this exoplanet is an ocean planet
the object lies very close to its host
star the average distance between them
measures just around 2 million
kilometers or 0.014 astronomical units
which is 75 times smaller than that
between the Earth and the Sun
also the orbit eccentricity is rather
high at 0.27 slightly more than that of
Pluto
this means that in its perihelion gliesa
1214b is approximately twice as close to
its star than when in its ophelion
as for its orbital period it takes the
planet about 36 hours to complete it
the Red Dwarf gleasa 1214 may be 300
times dimmer than the Sun but this
incredible proximity to the star makes
the climate on gleesa 1214b scorching
hot
supposing the reflection coefficient of
the surface of glisa 1214b is the same
as that of Venus the planet's surface
temperature is supposed to be around
393 Kelvin or 120 degrees Celsius
if on the other hand the surface is
darker the temperature May reach as much
as 553 Kelvin or 280 degrees Celsius
due to the fact that the orbit of glycer
1214b crosses the star's disk scientists
are able to carry out spectroscopic
investigations of its atmosphere
still the results are rather ambiguous
if this space object really is an ocean
planet its atmosphere is supposed to
predominantly consist of water vapor
with some accompanying gases
interestingly no lines of hydrogen
helium or complex substances like water
CO2 and ammonia have so far been
detected in the planet's Spectrum it is
stored that the outer layer of the dense
atmosphere conceals its true content
from The Observer
the conditions on the surface of glisa
1214b remind one of what it is like
inside a giant steam boiler
interestingly the atmospheric pressure
in its lower strata should be at least
15 times as highest out of the earth as
the ocean and the atmosphere are in a
state of thermodynamic equilibrium the
border between them is rather blurred no
wonder as the density of water vapor
just above the ocean's surface is
practically equal to that of constantly
boiling water
as we look deeper at the lower Strat of
the ocean the pressure will continue to
increase until we reach the depth of a
hundred kilometers
with a pressure value of this depth
water will be unable to remain in its
liquid state even at temperatures this
high and so we will see the bottom made
up of dense and heavy ice whose
thickness is estimated to be upwards of
5 000 kilometers
thus most water on the planet is
concentrated here
below the cryosphere there should be the
core made up of rocks and metals
unfortunately chances of Life evolving
on any ocean planet are rather thin even
if the surface temperature happens to be
more favorable than on this one this is
so due to the fact that oceans on
planets like that are too poor in terms
of micro elements that are vital for
living creatures
even taking into account meteorites that
occasionally bombard the surfaces of
these celestial bodies the chemical
diversity is simply not good enough for
life to originate here
still studying ocean planets poses a
great scientific interest
according to NASA's mathematical
modeling estimates published in 2020
there may be billions of planets of this
type in our galaxy both curled harboring
an ocean under an ice shell and warm
like gleesa 1214b
water is one of the most widespread
complex chemical compounds in the
universe and this means that the chances
of discovering new ocean planets are
quite optimistic
[Music]
650 light years away from the earth
their lies IRC plus 10 to 16.
a Majestic Star also known as CW leonis
its radius at its pulsation Peak May
reach 560 times that of the sun which is
about 2.6 times the distance from the
Earth to our parents star with C W
leonis hypothetically placed in the
middle of our system all the planets as
far as Mars would find themselves under
its surface which would even brush the
inner boundary of the asteroid belt
incidentally the star's mass is not that
great roughly 1.5 to 4 solar masses its
surface temperature is just 2 300 Kelvin
or about 2 000 degrees Celsius
but due to its impressive Dimensions the
star emits on average eight and a half
thousand times more energy than our sun
like any other red giant CW leonis is in
its final life stage
its age hasn't been defined precisely
but it is estimated to be several
billion years
it is assumed that in its solid days cew
leonis was a white blue star with a mass
three to five times that of the Sun
however by 1 billion years ago a great
part of the celestial body's hydrogen
had burned out and transformed into
helium
slowly settling in the star's Center the
helium ousted or the remaining hydrogen
and formed a scorching hot core which
did not participate in any thermonuclear
reactions
this process typical for All Stars whose
mass is close to that of the sun is the
starting point for a star's
transformation into a red giant
the star's inner pressure causes it to
expand to Great proportions which
renders the outer layers more rarified
and unstable
the space object's diameter grows to be
dozens of times greater with its color
gradually assuming a blood red hue
a thermonuclear reaction still takes
place in the star's depths which causes
the pressure and temperature of the
Stellar plasma to increase
at a certain point this unleashes a
chain reaction of nuclear fusion where
helium nuclei are transformed into
carbon
this is the so-called helium Flash
it is a complex multi-level physical
process that dramatically transforms the
stars in a structure
with its core incredibly heating up its
outer layers on the contrary cool off
and darken
there are currently great amounts of
carbon in CW Leones but its Mass isn't
sufficient to hit the next level of
nuclear synthesis
as a result the thermonuclear combustion
in the object's interior becomes
unstable the stalamata gradually cools
off and shrinks under the influence of
gravitation this heats up the star's
interior again and the reaction is
Unleashed with a new Force
after receiving a new portion of thermal
energy the Stellar matter expands again
and the combustion dies down
it is assumed that this cyclic process
underlies the occasional changes of the
star's luminosity
C.W leonis has a
649-day passation cycle and with the
Luminosity at its peak is 11 300 times
brighter than the sun
with the Luminosity at its lowest
meanwhile the object emits
6250 times more energy than the Sun
at the moment of contraction the upper
layers of Stellar Mata partly detach
themselves from the star
this forms a carbon oxygen gas nebula
that the star is enveloped in
According to some estimates CW leonis
loses 4 times 10 to the power of 22 tons
of material every year on account of
this process an amount approximately
seven times the mass of the Earth
observations show that the circumstellar
nebula is not less than 69 000 years old
and its mass is about 1.5 times that of
the Sun
as for its size it reaches 84 000
astronomical units
the nebula has an elaborate structure
with bulges and pockets of gas as well
as half arcs and irregular rings
it is posited that these formations
appeared due to Magnetic activity and
Stellar Wind generated by the unstable
star close by
the chemical composition of the cloud CW
leonis is shrouded in is of great
interest to explorers spectral analysis
data reveals it to contain around 70
different chemical compounds for example
carbon dioxide water and ammonia to name
but a few
there are also quite a lot of elements
from the upper part of mendeleev's
periodic table right down to iron
CW leonis may have had planets in the
past but they appear to have been
swallowed up early on at the stage of
expansion in any event years of
observations did not reveal distinct
traces of their existence in the past
what was registered was subtle changes
in the star's orbit back in 1994 and
more recently in 2017 mysterious shifts
of matter were detected in the cloud of
gas and dust enveloping the star
some small red dwarf orbiting the giant
could well account for these phenomena
although attempts to detect its
radiation have so far been unsuccessful
this could be due to the nebula close by
which disperses and reflects the energy
flow from sources of light located
nearby
this phenomenon camouflages any objects
in the immediate environs and prevents
them from being accurately recognized
the mass of C.W leonis's hypothetical
Stellar companion is assumed to be
definitely smaller than that of the sun
and it should take it approximately a
hundred years to complete a full orbit
around the Giant
another outstanding feature is a
comparatively high water content in the
star's environs and envelope
at first it was posited that the star
would melt and swallow up icy comets as
it expanded
however observations carried out in 2009
showed the temperature of some spectral
lines to reach a thousand Kelvin which
is possible early on condition that
water vapor forms actually in the upper
layers of the Giant
this fact did not fit in the model of
red giant structure accepted at a time
According to which all oxygen and
Stellar matter necessary for water
synthesis must be used up completely to
produce carbon monoxide
a new hypothesis was put forward to
account for the witnessed phenomena
which stated that molecules of silicon
oxides and carbon are destroyed by a
powerful ultraviolet radiation after
that the released oxygen reacts with
hydrogen and there forms scorching hot
water vapor
the weakness of this hypothesis is on
the failure to account for the source of
ultraviolet radiation
reactions like that may occur only in
rather high temperatures that is within
Stellar matter
however it is practically impervious to
cosmic rays
this Paradox may be explained by yet
another assumption since the star is
unstable large ruptures and low density
areas occasionally occur on its surface
where ultraviolet radiation is not
blocked out that effectively
the water Vapors overall mass in a
star's atmosphere and outer layers is
estimated at several quintillion tons
enormous though this figure may seem in
fact water accounts for just around a
billionth of the stars of Romas
according to today's Notions of Stellar
Evolution being a red giant CW leonis is
in its Autumn years now it will deplete
its Stellar fuel in the next 10 to 30
000 years after which it will discard
its outer layers following a powerful
explosion
it will transform into an incredibly hot
and dense space object
a wide dwarf
smass will be roughly 80 percent that of
the Sun and its temperature will reach
several million degrees in the first
seconds after the transformation
however with no energy source it is
destined to slowly and irrevocably fade
in the course of billions of years to
follow
eventually the celestial body will be
almost invisible against the background
of cosmic emptiness when it becomes a
mysterious black dwarf
but this will not happen anytime soon
the shock wave and the mind-boggling
temperature in the epicenter will
generate new elements that are not to be
found in a star's interior
for example uranium Golda lead they will
later become part of new celestial
objects
millions of years later yet radioactive
decay will heat the planet's Interiors
melt the ice as saturate the oceans with
micro elements thus creating conditions
for the Genesis of life
the universe is constantly evolving and
Global cataclysms and destruction are an
inalienable part of this process but at
the end of every storm there are fresh
rays of light
[Music]
foreign
in one of our previous videos we have
already taken a look at some terrifying
and lethally dangerous worlds discovered
in the vast expanses of space with some
of them extremely hot others are located
close to insanely powerful sources of
radiation and yet other ones are
peculiar for some bizarre features on
their surfaces however we haven't quite
exhausted our list of the most
horrifying planets and now it's time to
see some more
our first stop is 202 light years away
from the earth destination
k2-141 an orange dwarf
its mass is roughly 0.7 that of the Sun
and its radius measures 68 percent that
of our host star
with these parameters almost perfectly
proportional the star's temperature
reaches
4600 Kelvin
which is about 20 percent less than that
of the Sun
and now to the planet in question just
.007 astronomical units away from its
star there lies a really bizarre world
designation
k2-141b this Rocky exoplanet is five
times as massive as the Earth with its
radius 1.5 times as biggest out of our
Earth
all this gives us grounds to assume that
the gravity on the planet's surface is
at least twice as strong as that on our
planet the heavy metallic core meanwhile
accounts for 20 to 50 percent of the
planet's overall Mass it takes the
celestial body about six and a half
hours to complete a full orbit around
its parent star being extremely close it
is steadily locked to it that is it
faces a star with one in the same side
at all times observations show that the
temperature on the planet's day side
reaches
3270 Kelvin or 3000 degrees Celsius
this is enough not only to melt most
rocks and metals but also to effectively
evaporate them
the day side of the planet is assumed to
be covered with a lava ocean that never
ceases to boil the atmosphere is thought
to be rather exotic made up of steams of
heavy metals and silicates
by contrast the planet's night side is
incredibly freezing according to
estimates the temperature of most of its
area is tens of times lower than that on
the day side and on balance its values
are supposed to be Sub-Zero
mathematical modeling shows that this
sharp temperature contrast gives rise to
exceptionally strong winds whose speed
reaches 1.75 kilometers per second
this is roughly five times the speed of
sound which means that the surface of
k2-141b is continuously shaken by
exceptionally powerful deafening
rumbling
it is assumed that on reaching the night
side atmospheric streams condense and
precipitate on its surface in the form
of fiery rain
this forms lava rivers and eventually
this mountain metal makes its way back
into a magma ocean to evaporate again
later on and to continue this incredible
fiery circulation
however this infernal cycle affects only
a relatively small part of the planet's
night side the thing is that masses of
evaporated elements from the day side
simply don't make it to the main part of
the night side and precipitate somewhere
on the border that is why the central
part of the night side is likely to be a
freezing desert bound with layers of
solid rocks
remarkably
k2-141b is far from being the hottest
planet that we know of
for example there is an object referred
to as couch 9B lying 670 light years
away from the Earth
its surface is as hot as 4600 Kelvin
which is approximately
4330 degrees Celsius
just to compare the outer layers of
almost all red dwarves for example are
much cooler which means that in terms of
temperature this exoplanet is quite a
match to Stars
its parent star designation celt 9 is of
a whitish blue color and has a mass 2.6
times that of the Sun
as for his diameter it is 2.3 times that
of our star
the surface temperature of calc 9 is
rather high at approximately 10
170 Kelvin or a staggering
9900 degrees Celsius this largely
accounts for the extreme conditions on
count 9B which lies quite close by
just .035 astronomical units away from
its parent star the planet completes a
full orbit around its system's Center
roughly every one and a half days
celt 9B is a hot gas giant compared to
Jupiter its mass is 2.8 times as big and
its radius measures roughly twice as
much as that of the largest planet in
our system
based on today's Notions about the
composition of this type of planets the
inner part of count 9b's atmosphere is
supposed to be even hotter estimates
allow for this value to reach as much as
11 000 Kelvin on account of heavy metal
ionization
with this figure so exceptionally big it
appears that the planet's atmosphere
should contain vaporized iron and
titanium alongside the elements we're
used to in an atmosphere's composition
such as hydrogen or helium
its close proximity to the parent star
and the extremely high temperature
caused the planet to gradually lose its
atmosphere
by and by powerful Stellar Wind Blows it
off into space which is why the object
is shrouded in a cloud of rarified gas
this material will eventually be
attracted and absorbed by the star
interestingly According to some
estimates the exoplanet loses up to 68
Earth masses every billion years
theoretically in a long while celt9b May
well get stripped of all of its
atmosphere and transform itself into a
theonian planet
however its parent star is likely to hit
the final stage of its life cycle long
before that swallowing up and destroying
all the celestial objects within its
reach
the space objects we have just looked at
are a living proof as it were of the
fact that stars can destroy the planets
close to them and not just warm them up
but incidentally there are celestial
objects out there in the universe that
have experienced their parent stars
wroth in full measure one of such
objects lies
4570 light years away from the earth in
the environs of a small star designation
v391 pegasi now the star is a white
dwarf whose masses twice as little as
data's son and whose radius is
approximately 23 percent that of our
parents star the temperature of the
celestial object is unbelievably high at
almost 30 000 Kelvin all thermonuclear
reactions in its interior would have run
their course a long while ago
up ahead are hundreds of billions of
years of slow cooling with the white
dwarf eventually transforming into a
black one
the planets we will look at referred to
as v391 Pegasi b is in this ordinary
stars in virus its slot is exceptionally
amazing according to mathematical
modeling the planet not only survived
its progenitor star shedding its outer
layers but actually found itself almost
within the star for some time it is
assumed that when the system's star v391
pegasi transformed into a red giant its
outer layers extremely rarefied by then
we're almost brushing the planet's orbit
their density became dozens of times
lower than the atmospheric air we're
used to which means that the celestial
objects devoured by the dying star
remained whole for a while and didn't
get destroyed at once
it goes without saying that they would
have been losing their speed and dropped
into the Stars hotter and Dancer layers
still the 391 pegasi shed its outer
layers sooner than v391 Pegasi b melted
and ceased to exist as a whole object at
the moment the exoplanet appears to be a
gas giant three times as massive as
Jupiter its orbit passes 1.7
astronomical units away from its parent
star and it takes the planet
approximately
1170 Earth days to complete a full orbit
around its system center it is still not
entirely clear how this astronomical
body managed to preserve such a big Mass
after its collision with a scorching hot
layers of the star their influence was
supposed to have destroyed the object's
atmosphere completely
however there is no doubt that the
host's Stars collapse brought about some
dramatic changes both in terms of the
exoplanet's orbit and its parameters
that is why it is hardly possible for us
to ever find out what v391 Pegasi b was
like before immersing in a sea of raging
plasma
space expanses can seal uncountable
astronomical objects with the most
bizarre properties some of them are
almost totally invisible through regular
telescopes but can be detected by
looking at Radio wavelengths when
exploring space
an example of such like celestial
objects is pulsars neutron stars
spinning on their axes at a
mind-boggling speed these object Spectra
are peculiar for exceptionally fast and
regular pulsations that is why it is
quite easy to detect another Celestial
body transiting between a radiation
Source like that and an observer on the
Earth
this is precisely the way our next
object of Interest was discovered but
first we'll be looking at a passer which
lies around 4 000 light years away from
the earth this neutron star boasts quite
a long name here it is on the screen and
now let's check out its remarkable
features the pulsar's diameter is just a
measly 20 kilometers and its mass is
approximately 1.4 out of the Sun the
object spins at an incredible rate with
roughly 10 000 rotations a minute while
continuously emitting powerful
electromagnetic radiation impulses now
the surface of the exoplanet our next
object of interest is continuously
exposed to these waves of lethal
radiation which makes it a hostile and
forbidding place
it takes this planet just two hours to
complete a full orbit around its system
center and the distance to the Pulsar is
smaller than the sun's radius just 600
000 kilometers or 0.004 astronomical
units
incidentally the celestial body's
surface is bound by Eternal code and
space as its parent star just barely
emits thermal energy the object's mass
is around 330 that of the earth while
its radius is four times that of our
planet
this makes gravity on its surface as
much as 20 times stronger than on the
Earth
estimates show the planet's average
density to be about 23 grams per cubic
centimeter which is more than most
chemical compounds we know the planet is
thought to be made up for the most part
of crystallized carbon under a lot of
pressure
sides the object's upper layers contain
some oxygen which is probably chemically
bound with carbon
it is highly doubtful that a Celestial
body located so close to a star could
possibly have survived a supernova event
it is more realistic to assume that the
EXO planet formed after the progenitor
Star had come to the end of its life
cycle and had transformed itself into a
pulsar the exoplanet could be a piece of
debris left over from a white dwarf
whose material would have dispersed for
the most part
this makes classifying the exoplanet an
especially difficult task
still whatever it is this world remains
one of the most dangerous and hostile
ones lurking in the depths of the cosmos
foreign
object that absorbs all light shed on it
is a challenging task to say the least
that is why there are not that many
confirmed black hole candidates today
still mathematical modeling shows that
their number in our galaxy May reach 100
million
this may seem an incredibly big number
but since there are 200 to 400 billion
stars in the Milky Way it makes us
realize that in all these expanses black
holes or objects one doesn't come across
that much
in one of our previous videos on the
topic we mentioned that a star the
progenitor of a black hole has to have a
mass of at least 18 to 20 solar masses
only this will ensure a powerful enough
Supernova to compress the scorching hot
core of the star to an exceptionally
dense clump of material
after this has occurred nothing will be
able to stand up to the object's Gravity
Force and Escape beyond the boundaries
of a conventional sphere predefined by
the so-called Schwartz Shield radius
what used to be a star transforms into a
bizarre object with an inner makeup that
would defy description by the physical
laws we're familiar with
the object referred to as
a0620-00 or v616 is one of the black
holes closest to our Earth that we know
of
it lies
3300 light years away from our planet
and forms part of a binary star in the
constellation monosaurus
the other object in the system is an
orange dwarf with a mass half that of
the Sun
every 7.75 hours it completes the full
orbit around an invisible object of
unknown nature
estimates show the mass of this
invisible object to be around 6.6 times
that of the sun it is admittedly too
much for a neutron star this leads one
to believe that the bizarre invisible
object is more likely than not a black
hole
in addition to getting deformed and
elongated by the more massive neighbor's
Gravity the orange dwarf is also getting
stripped of the outer layers of Stellar
Mata
spiraling streams of scorching gas
gradually flow to the black hole and
form a bright accretion disk
it is thanks to this dazzling disc that
the black hole was detected
there are at least several dozen stars
in the environs of v616
some of which almost certainly have
their own planetary systems
it is highly likely that in the future
one of these Stars will get dangerously
close to the black hole and as a result
will be sucked in by the object's insane
gravity
this unfortunate star will have no
choice and in this case the same slow
demise is eventually awaiting the black
hole's new companion as that of its
current one
the process of interaction of a black
hole with other objects largely depends
on their Mass ratio
the smaller the distance between them
and the more massive the black hole the
stronger the influence of its stidal
forces over its companion the star may
be deformed by them and gets stretched
towards the system's common Mass center
they can also form channels that would
carry Stellar matter closer to the black
hole adding up to its accretion disk
if the tidal forces happen to be strong
enough they may well destroy the object
that is being sucked in by turning it
into a fiery ring
it is assumed that there may be planets
orbiting a black hole just as if it were
a regular star in contrast to a
widespread opinion black holes are
actually not able to suck in all objects
around them indiscriminately
from the point of view of gravitation in
astronomical terms they behave just like
any star with the same mass
that is why incredibly though it may
seem a black hole May well have a stable
planetary system
there are several ways for them to form
firstly new celestial objects may
originate in a nebula of gas and dust
that is formed after a supernova
influenced by gravitation their first
form clumps of material that collide
with each other and attract Cosmic dust
as a result they eventually turn into
planets and satellites as well as large
numbers of small celestial objects like
asteroids and comets
the radiation of the black hole's
accretion disk may be powerful enough to
warm them and even melt ice on their
surfaces
hypothetically a planetary system like
that could be favorable enough for life
to originate and with any luck evolve
secondly when a black hole captures and
destroys another planetary system some
of its objects may choose to take up
stable orbital positions around their
new host
of course this makeover would bring
about dramatic changes on the celestial
object's surfaces
thus a nice giant May transform into an
ocean planet and a gas giant may lose
almost all of its hydrogen and turn into
a thonian planet
thirdly space Wanderers like rogue
planets or Interstellar asteroids may
also be ensnared by the massive object's
gravity
even though systems like that have not
yet been discovered in practice there is
no reason to suppose they're
non-existent
if on the other hand a planet is too
close to the system's Center and the
black hole is massive enough other
factors come into play
a scorching hot stream of material
forming the accretion disk will strip
the celestial object of its atmosphere
and its friction will slow it down and
pull it still closer to the black hole
eventually extremely powerful tidal
forces will rip the planet to Tiny
shreds the debris will be pulled into
the accretion disk and gradually melt in
the hot gas around
in the end they will inevitably get
swallowed up by the black hole and in
essence become part of it
it is positive that there are three main
types of black holes to be found in the
universe at a different first and
foremost in terms of our Mass the first
type can be found in the center of most
spiral galaxies
these are gargantuan black holes with
masses reaching several billion solar
masses
the density of matter in the central
part of a galaxy is generally extremely
high which is the reason why there
originates a big number of large and
bright stars quite closely packed as
they rapidly burn out they transform
into black holes which in their turn
rapidly grow and often merge with each
other
as a result supermassive objects are
born which are surrounded with giant
accretion disks made of scorching hot
material they alumin space so brightly
that it makes them seen from billions of
light years away even if their galaxies
completely unobservable to us these
objects are known as quasars
the second type is much more widespread
but at the same time black holes like
these are not that easily detectable
their masses are close to those of stars
and they form out of large Stars at the
end of the latter's life cycle
by devouring other celestial bodies and
Interstellar gas these objects gradually
gain in size and eventually turn into
intermediate Mass black holes they can
also merge together which generates
gravity waves to distort space many
light years around
the third type is the hypothetical
primary black holes their existence has
been inferred from today's theory of
universes Origins and evolution
fluctuations and matter that filled
space in its early stages of evolution
may have been favorable for Black Hills
of infinitely small size to originate
it should be mentioned that according to
estimates the smaller an object of this
type the faster it evaporates and at the
end of its life cycle it turns into a
tremendously powerful electromagnetic
impulse
modeling shows that primary black holes
with masses around 10 to the power of 12
kilograms are supposed to be flaring up
sometime around now but to date no such
event has been registered yet
according to a certain hypothesis a
microscopic black hole may form on
collision of extra high energy
Elementary particles this variety is
referred to as Quantum black holes
still the conditions necessary for such
an event to happen are impossible to be
reproduced in lab conditions and
estimated life expectancy of these
hypothetical objects is so small that it
can hardly be measured with today's
latest and most advanced methods
that is why Quantum Black Hills still
officially exist only in theory
of course it is extremely difficult to
detect such dark and compact objects
some of them happen to have a star
companion whose anomalous trajectory of
movement gives Telltale prompts of there
being an invisible thing in close
proximity
another popular method of detection is
observation of accretion disks these
object Spectra have some typical
features that allow telling them from
other sources of light in space
sometimes we're lucky enough to get a
snapshot of a disc with a black spot in
it that is evidence that the observed
object structure is quite unusual
a black hole may also be detected thanks
to the gravitational micro lensing
effect this involves detecting the
massive invisible object as it transits
between the Earth and a remote star this
changes the star's Spectrum in a special
way
but admittedly this method requires a
number of rare factors to successfully
work
there is hardly any doubt that space is
filled with great numbers of objects
that are dark and not easily noticeable
there may be wandering black holes among
them
these mysterious objects roaming around
in interstellar space and absorbing
every bit of light they come across will
probably never reveal their secrets to
us
[Music]
long before telescopes had been invented
people could observe a light strip
crossing the heavens
the fascinating and mysterious
phenomenon prompted a multitude of
Legends but it took thousands of years
of scientific progress to finally
account for it
it turned out that the Milky Way wasn't
a path of Gods
what it is is the dissipated light of
billions of stars to remote to
distinguish each one separately
the idea of the Stars around us making
our part of a single structure of
enormous Dimensions was first suggested
by Emmanuel Kant back in 1755. he also
assumed that some nebulae discovered by
scientists could in fact be remote star
clusters that is other galaxies
this ingenious guess was well ahead of
its time but the Philosopher's
contemporaries initially dismissing it
only in the early 20th century did the
progress of observation equipment enable
scientists to confirm the existence of
other galaxies and in 1936 Edwin Hubble
devised a classification system
many of its principles are still
referred to by scientists today
according to the system the Milky Way
falls into the category of barred spiral
galaxies although it took a long while
before it had assumed this today's looks
our galaxy is quite a nailed one says
the stars in its Central globular
clusters were born as far back as around
13 billion years ago
at the same time there are some areas in
the Milky Way where stars are actively
born which means that there is always a
fresh supply of young Stars
the collected data points to the fact
that the Milky Way is a comparatively
large Galaxy in astronomical terms the
diameter of its disk measures as much as
200 000 light years with a Halo reaching
out into space much deeper yet our
galaxies home to at least 200 billion
various stars as well as 25 to 100
billion browned wolves
in addition it contains over a trillion
planets countless small celestial
objects as well as clouds of cosmic dust
and Interstellar gas which may reach
gigantic dimensions
at the same time regular Mata accounts
for a small ratio in the galaxy
around 90 percent of the Milky Way's
overall mass is the so-called dark
matter
the amount of light emitted by this
mysterious and widespread substance is
negligible
however Dark Matter plays an active role
in gravitational interaction
even though most of the galactic Mass
remains invisible we can still calculate
it to that end scientists refer to stars
trajectories of movement around the
center of the Milky Way
according to the estimates the overall
mass of our galaxy reaches 0.8 to 1.5
trillion solar masses
the structure of the Milky Way is quite
elaborate
we'll start our journey today from its
Center
this area of the Galaxy is shrouded in
massive clouds of gas and dust
but by a happy chance we can observe it
through the so-called bardess window an
area of space with lower amounts of dust
just like most spiral galaxies the Milky
Way has a supermassive black hole in its
Center which is surrounded with an
accretion disk with a radius roughly
three light years
dubbed Sagittarius A star it is the
closest object to this class to us
its mass is 4.3 million solar masses and
its radius isn't over 16 million
kilometers which is three times smaller
than Mercury's orbit
the First Data about the nature of the
object in the center of our galaxy was
acquired in the course of long
observations and thorough calculations
early as recently as on May 12 2022 was
it possible to get the first image with
the help of the EHT network of radio
telescopes and so the earlier hypotheses
were confirmed
the area in the center of our galaxy is
highly populated
more than 6 000 stars have already been
detected within three light years from
the black hole with the orbits of some
of them defined rather accurately for
example there is a white blue star
designation s62 which is 17.8
astronomical units away from the black
hole on its closest approach to it while
moving at 6.7 percent the speed of light
classical mechanics laws are inadequate
for description of the trajectory of
movement of a star as Swift as that
because of relativistic effects
just to illustrate the axis of its orbit
shifts by 75 angular minutes with every
completed orbit besides when Crossing
this area in space we can see several
large star clusters with a total mass of
around 1 million solar masses
and slightly further roughly 200 light
years away another massive black hole is
likely to be lurking whose Mass should
be around a hundred thousand times that
of the Sun
traveling further on we will reach the
central molecular cloud and irregularly
shaped area measuring 1600 to 1900 light
years whose mass is over 60 million
solar masses
there are great many Stellar nurseries
and gas nebulae as well as protostars
and remnants of supernovae most of the
clouds matter is dense hydrogen whose
temperature fluctuates between 50 and
600 Kelvin which corresponds to 223
degrees Celsius below zero to 327
degrees Celsius above zero spectral
analysis shows the gigantic nebula to
contain carbon monoxide methyl alcohol
and hydrocyanic acid in addition to
hydrogen
having receded from the Milky Way's
Center a bit we will see that it is
encompassed by a bulge a bright and
massive formation of an elliptical shape
with its length reaching 10 000 light
years its transverse diameter is roughly
seven light years
the total mass of the Bulge is as much
as 10 billion times that of the Sun
the exact number of the Stars cannot be
calculated because their radiation
Blends and renders any estimates
unrealistic
being elongated the Bulge forms the
circled bar stretching for approximately
13 000 light years and serving as the
base for spiral Galactic arms
it is here at one of its Sands that we
can see the star cluster Stevenson too
containing the largest known star today
its designation is Stevenson 2-18 and
its radius is 2
150 times that of the Sun
unfortunately chances of finding
exoplanets orbiting this outstanding
object are quite minuscule even if
planets did exist at some point in the
past the hyper giant would have
swallowed them up while it was expanding
the Galaxy's Center is home to billions
of stars and apparently a great number
of exoplanets
chances of encountering a potentially
habitable World among this great
multitude are much lower than in less
populated areas of the Galaxy
this is due to the fact that when a big
number of stars are located close
together they destabilize exoplanets
orbits while their powerful radiation is
lethal to all living things
that is why a special area in the galaxy
is defined as the habitable zone it
looks like a ring with a radius
measuring 22 to 29 000 light years and
contains star systems with the most
favorable conditions for the Genesis of
biological life
Worlds encompassed by the ring languish
in exposure to excessive radiation while
beyond the ring there's a lack of heavy
elements
however mathematical modeling shows that
stars within galaxies are able to
migrate thousands of light years away
thus either leaving the habitable zone
or entering it
consequently with an exoplanet lying
within the Zone it does not
automatically suggest favorable
conditions on it
moving on away from the center of the
Milky Way we will have a chance to check
out its most impressive part
the galactic disc
it is made up of two components with
different properties
the first one known as the Thin disc
measures one thousand to one thousand
three hundred light years and thickness
and its visible radius measures as much
as 50 000 light years on the edge it
gradually dissipates with the outermost
Stars lying up to a hundred thousand
light years away from the Galaxy's
Center
this part of the Milky Way contains
around 80 percent of the Galaxy's
visible mass and in fact it was the last
component to have formed
as for the thick disk its diameter is
comparable to that of the thin disc but
it's four times a stick and is much more
rarified
it is made up of old stars and is
practically devoid of interstellar gas
observations of some stars in the Milky
Way as well as mathematical modeling
show our galaxy to have swallowed up
another one in the period from 11 to 8
billion years ago this hypothetical
Cosmic structure was dubbed Gaia
Enceladus
it is thought that it contributed
several billion stars to the Milky Way
as well as great amounts of interstellar
gas and dark matter
it is thanks to this tremendous event
that most of our Galaxy's stick disc
formed and an additional supply of gas
led to a stellar baby boom
there is no doubt that spiral arms are
the most noticeable structural elements
of our Galaxy's disk
usually two major ones are singled out
The scutum Centaurus arm and the Perseus
arm and two minor ones the Norma arm and
the Karina Sagittarius arm sometimes a
fifth large arm is taken into account
named after the cygnis constellation
Galactic arms are areas of especially
High star count most of interstellar gas
is also concentrated here which is why
the rate of star formation in the arms
is three to five times higher than in
the Galaxy on average
they spend the first millions of their
lives in open clusters but gravity
forces are too weak to hold the Stars
close together for a long time this
destabilizes the Clusters and young
Stars gradually drift away from each
other
traveling along the Karina Sagittarius
arm we will reach a fork that links it
to the Perseus arm
the length of this Stellar structure
reaches 11 000 light years and its width
measures roughly
3500 light years it is referred to as
the Orion arm and it is here 27
000 light years away from the Galaxy's
Center but the solar system is located
from our planet's perspective the
Galaxy's Center is seen as a dark abyss
this is the Great Rift an area of space
that shuts out the greater part of the
Milky Way from our gaze
it is filled with massive clouds of
interstellar gas and dust and its total
mass is as much as a million times that
of the Sun
even though the Great Rift is
practically not transparent in the
optical range its matter actively emits
radio waves and thermal energy
spectral analysis data reveals that the
clouds are mostly made up of hydrogen
with a small percentage of more complex
compounds ammonia alcohols and amino
acids
the Great Rift is thought to be a
potential Stellar Nursery but it is
going to take a while until the first
Stars light up in that area
while it is still not quite active let's
move on beyond the Galaxy disk
even though it's bright and clearly
defined arms attract a lot of attention
there is more to the Milky Way than that
[Music]
if we look closer we will see the vast
and the most rarified of its components
the Halo
its visible part spherical and shape
stretches for up to 260
000 light years away from the Galaxy's
Center but accounts for just a few
percent of the total mass
the Halo contains a great number of
globular clusters made up of remarkably
old Stars over 12 billion years of age
and several tremendous Stellar streams
the Sagittarius stream for example made
up of several thousand stars encompasses
our galaxy in an elongated Ellipsis
which is almost perpendicular to the
main plane
modeling shows that all these stars are
highly likely to have been
gravitationally captured by the Milky
Way from a dwarf satellite Galaxy
designations Sagittarius deg
it lies 500 000 light years away from
the Milky Way's Center and is going to
be swallowed up by it completely within
several billion years
another dwarf galaxy has already met a
similar fate
lying in the Canis Major constellation
it was almost destroyed by the Milky Way
which pulled out millions of its Stars
by gravity forces
stretching for two hundred thousand
light years and mixing with other stars
this string of stars with a total mass
of roughly 100 million solar masses has
already wrapped around our galaxy three
times
apart from Bright but rare stars and
clusters the Halo contains great amounts
of gas whose temperature reaches
millions of Kelvin
also great amounts of dark matter are
thought to be scattered in the vicinity
of the Milky Way forming the so-called
dark Halo
stretching for up to 2 million light
years it hardly emits any
electromagnetic radiation and can be
detected only by gravitational
interaction
the dark Halo remains an unsolved
mystery yet it greatly contributes to
the global stability of our galaxy
the diversity of space objects is truly
fascinating
with some of them spread all over the
place others are absolutely unique
every corner in space Harbors countless
Mysteries and whenever some of them are
solved they add to our knowledge about
the universe around us
are we to solve all its Mysteries
someday time will show